for much of human history we were kind
of like the llms figuring things out by
kind of matching patterns in our minds
but then came more systematic
formalization and eventually computation
and with that we got a whole other level
of power to truly create new things and
to in effect go wherever we want in the
ruad but the challenge is to do that in
a way that connects with what we humans
and our AIS understand you know I I know
that you make a big thing about the way
that we measure and observe the Universe
rests upon that sort of notion of things
having temporal persistence I I guess
that the same kind of commitment is
inherent in assuming that there is a
non-equilibrium steady state solution to
the Dynamics you in in a classical uh in
a classical formulation human language
mathematics logic these are all ways to
formalize the world and in our Century
there's a new and yet more powerful one
computation for nearly 50 years is I've
had the great privilege of building up
an ever taller Tower of Science and
Technology that's based on that idea of
computation is this a fact of physics
that the world is predictable enough
that an observer who can sort of
continue to exist is possible I mean
this is something which I think from
from my understanding of of fundamental
physics one of the things that is not
obvious is that an observer who persists
in time is possible in the universe and
that that very existence the emergence
of an
observer is would manifest to us and
indeed does manifest to us as a kind of
intelligence a kind of sentience that
may or may not have some kind of deep
planning uh associated with it I i' I've
been interested in in trying to
characterize what our observers like us
like and the the thing in our physics
project that's really the the kind of
the the sort of motivation for that
is that there is this thing we call the
ruad this kind of entangled limit of all
possible computations which is in a
sense has everything in it for me two
critical features of observers like us
are that we are computationally bounded
we have sort of only finite Minds we
can't entangle every detail of what
might be happening in the universe we
can only look at sort of aggregated uh
large scale features so computation
isn't just a possible formalization it's
the ultimate one for our
universe it all starts from the idea
that space like matter is made of
discrete
elements and from that uh structure of
space and everything in it it it's it's
defined just by a network of relations
between these elements that we might
call atoms of space so it's all very
elegant but deeply
abstract but here's kind of a humanized
representation a version of the very
beginning of the universe and what we're
seeing here is the emergence of space
and everything in it by the successive
application of very simple computational
rules and remember these dots are not
atoms in any existing space they're
atoms of space that get put together to
make space The Observer thinks there
standing still The Observer is not
zipping around all over the place The
Observer believes they're stuck they're
persistent in time and they're stuck in
more or less the same place in space if
we didn't have that we wouldn't be able
to make a video that anybody recognizes
even though the underlying Connections
in all these hypergraphs are all
absolutely correct we just wouldn't be
able to see that so it's a um so in that
sense uh you know we can say that to an
observer with those
characteristics yes
black holes are persistent things and
yes if we kept going long enough we
could build our whole universe this way
so eons later here's a chunk of space
with two little black holes that uh if
we wait a little while will eventually
merge uh generating little ripples of
gravitational radiation and remember all
of this is built from Pure computation
but like fluid mechanics emerging from
molecules what emerges here is spacetime
and Einstein's equations for Gravity our
computational rules can inevitably be
applied in many ways uh each defining a
different kind of thread of time a
different path of history that can
branch and merge but as observers
embedded in this universe we're
branching and merging too and it turns
out that quantum mechanics emerges as
the story of how branching Minds
perceive a branching universe so the
little pink lines you might be able to
see here show the structure of what we
call branchial space the space of
quantum branches and one of the
stunningly beautiful things at least for
physicist like me is that the same
phenomenon that in physical space gives
us gravity in branchial space gives us
quantum
mechanics so in the history of science
so far I think we can identify sort of
four broad
paradigms the for making models of the
world that can be distinguished kind of
by how they deal with time so in
Antiquity and in plenty of of science
even today it's all about kind of what
are things made of and time doesn't
really enter but in the 1600s came the
idea of modeling things with
mathematical formulas in which time
enters but basically just as a
coordinate value then in 1980s and this
is something in which I was deeply
involved came the idea of making models
uh by starting with simple computational
rules and just letting them run so can
one predict what will happen no the
there's what I call computational
irreducibility in which in effect the
passage of time corresponds to an
irreducible computation that we have to
run in order to work out how it will
turn out but now there's kind of
something something even more in our
physics project there's things have
become multic computational with many
threads of time that can only knitted be
knitted together by an observer I'm I'm
I'm remembering when I was like 15 years
old or something maybe 14 years old or
something I went to some t by some
well-known physicist uh and you know I I
sort of said well you know they were
talking about black holes and I was like
is there something you know similar
between electrons and black holes and it
was like no no no that's completely
silly idea you know you should forget
that idea so you know I talked about
building up the universe by repeatedly
applying a computational rule but how is
that rule picked well actually it isn't
because all possible rules are used and
we're building up what I call the ruad
the kind of deeply abst ract but unique
object that is the entangled limit of
all possible computational processes
here's a a tiny fragment of it shown in
terms of touring machines so this this
ruad is everything and we as observers
are necessarily part of it in the ruad
as a whole in a sense everything
computationally possible can happen but
observers like us just sample specific
slices of the ruad and there are two
crucial facts about us
first we're computationally bounded our
minds are limited and second we believe
we're persistent in time even though
we're made of different atoms of space
at every moment so then here's the big
result what observers with those
characteristics perceive in the ruad
necessarily follows certain laws and
those laws turn out to be precisely the
three key theories of 20th century
physics general relativity quantum
mechanics and statistical mechanics in
the second law so it's because because
we're observers like us that we perceive
the laws of physics we do we can think
of sort of different Minds as being at
different places in Ral space human
Minds who think alike and nearby animals
further away and further out we get to
kind of alien Minds where it's hard to
make a translation I would suspect that
there is something which you
are something interesting which you're
effectively taking ex acatic about
observers and and perhaps perhaps some
uh that I mean in a sense one of the
things I'm trying to do right now is to
think about what aspects of observers
are in fact there but we've always
thought they were obvious and one of the
things that's really dramatic in that
simulation is how much activity there is
in the background of space that is that
space in order to exist has to have a
lot of activity just to knit together
the different pieces of space could we
think our way out of it I think we
possibly could in a sort of um science
fiction sense simply because we've got
the right kinds of models of our lived
World which is just the physics that
you're talking about but lots of other
observers would not be able to do that
unless they had that right kind of
internal model that implicit um way of
modeling the causes of uh all of my
Sensations I mean I think you were
talking about thingness so to speak
which is a lower bar probably than
Observer I mean thingness might just be
the ability to maintain an independent
object maintain something that we can
consider to be a persistent object is
Chris Fields Chris fields and so he he
um frames exactly what um you were just
saying in terms of there being little
pockets of concentrated planning sort of
um sort of self-modeling of the kind
that invokes the consequences of one's
own agent he'd articulate that in terms
of a minimal markof blanket so something
that cannot be reduced that has if you
like the capacity to be an agent and
then it sees itself enacting its plans
through a hierarchy of subsequent
Markoff blankets so you could say that
the you know the inclusive Markoff
blanket around this little packet or
or irreducible Markoff blanket was an
agent but the agency sits at the heart
and of course he thinks that's
Consciousness you're both absolutely
brilliant and I think Tim and I both
look up to you quite a bit so this is
actually a pretty terrifying situation
for me like you
knower so look there's there's no real
way to uh to order two of one's Heroes
so I just I just went to the tried
andrue alphabetical so we're just gonna
we're gonna introduce uh Dr priston and
then Dr Wolfram so
Dr friston welcome back to the show you
are an esteemed British scientist who is
widely recognized for groundbreaking
quantitative uh methods to understand
the human brain a professor at The
Institute of Neurology University
College London friston invented
statistical parametric mapping and voxal
based morphometry two neuroimaging
techniques that have revolutionize the
field Dr friston has published over a
thousand papers in science ific journals
making him one of the most cited
scientists he is the originator of
dynamic causal modeling and the much
acclaimed free energy principle a
deceptively simple and yet profoundly
impactful idea that has fundamentally
reshaped our understanding of the brain
and living systems more recently he
accepted a role as Chief scientist at
versus AI a company implementing
cognitive Computing and distributed
intelligence welcome back to the show
it's great to be here and can I just say
it's a great honor to be here with
Steven wfr we I don't think we've ever
actually met and it's it's lovely to see
you and very nice to meet you
too yeah and Dr stepen Wolfram you are a
renowned British American Computer
scientist physicist and business leader
known for your considerable
contributions to multiple scientific
domains as the founder and CEO o of the
Innovative software company Wolfram
research he developed Mathematica a
comprehensive computation environment
along with the Wolfram language an
original symbolic language that greatly
Alters the interaction with computation
as an early Pioneer in theoretical
physics cellular automata and complexity
theory he wrote the best-selling book A
New Kind of Science arguing for a
fundamental shift in scientific
paradigms more recently he launched the
Wolfram physics project ambitiously
aspiring to build up a fundamental
theory of all physics from a
computational
foundation for his influential work he
has achieved numerous accolades
including being the youngest MacArthur
Fellowship winner wolfram's
transformative approach continues to
impact the landscape of computational
Science and Beyond and welcome back to
the show you've been on a few times with
us now yes great great to be back and
this this is you know I I have been
meaning to learn what does Carl freston
really do so this is my opportunity to
to do that so I'm looking forward to
this and uh uh am I allowed to just jump
in and start talking about oh yeah AB
absolutely yeah of course please do I
I've been I'm I'm sort of curious how
horribly wrong I am in my sort
of vague idea of of uh of of Carl and
his free energy principle and so on so
so see let me let me try my version of
this and then you can tell me what's
what's horribly wrong with it um I mean
it's kind of like if you're
a a brain likee thing you kind of the
the concept I think is that you want the
world to be as predictable a place as
possible and that it can be predictable
either because you have a great model of
what's going to happen or because you've
organized your world so that it is set
up to be predictable you know we we we
um uh we kind of uh you know part of
what we try to achieve with technology
and things is to make our lives sort of
uh
um uh more predictable and I suppose my
my assumption is that I mean I first of
all am I am I roughly right in what the
what the point is here am I totally
totally off base no no you're you're
perfectly right I mean that's almost um
word for word how how I would portray
the sort of theological implications of
the fre energy principle to
psychologists and neurobiologists and
other sort of theoreticians in the Life
Sciences I should say if I was talking
to a physicist and now I
am and just want to um say that I'm only
an intuitive physicist you know I've
forgotten all the physics I did um when
I was was when when I was a young man
but if I were trying to explain
physicist um then everything you said is
exactly right but inverted um so if
things exist and thingness is defined in
terms of establishing some kind of
synchrony or some kind of
non-equilibrium steady state with
everything else or particularly the
local niche in which it finds itself
then it can always be read as if it is
trying to predict what is happening and
exactly as you say engineer or design
its Niche so to as to make things more
predictable so it's one of Dand strange
inversions so part of the Simplicity of
the um the free energy principle lies in
that um almost
torical um framing of the free energy
principle whereby you're just saying
that if something exists in harmony um
and um in relation to its envir
enironment then it will show these kinds
of properties that can on a on a certain
reading be interpreted as minimizing
surprise maximizing predictability but
there are lots of nuances and and I
would like to know you know how this
might fit into um what we were talking
about before going on air you know the
ruad and your conception of the you know
how the universe unfolds and what part
of that what slice of that constitutes
the thing The Observer and how it
relates to you know the context in which
which it is it is
evolving yeah I think that's that's
interesting but let let me see if I can
paraphrase what you just said you
basically said that for an organism to
be sort of Happily going along as you
said in harmony with its environment it
is inevitable you say that it must have
achieved this minimiz of surprise this
maximization of predictability is is
that right I mean that that's some uh so
so in other words that that somehow um
if if things were still dynamically
changing and you know the world was
becoming a different place for example
and equilibrium of the type you
described had not been achieved then as
I understand it you would not expect
your your sort of uh um well I I I I
kind of the the term free energy uh kind
of confuses me a bit because you know
I'm I'm used to kind of a physics
version of that which I think is not
quite the same as what you're talking
about but let's say um you're uh let's
talk about you're saying
that so let let me ask in a in a
situation where the world is changing do
you anticipate that this minimization of
surprise so to speak still is still
there or do you think there's a a
different thing that might be more like
a a non-equilibrium version of
thermodynamics as compared to a sort of
equilibrium uh things are going along
with with in the case of thermodynamics
maximization of entropy in in your case
a minimization of surprise or or did I
misunderstand that well no that's an
excellent question so strictly speaking
the free energy principle does assume
that there is some steady state but it
it is a non-e equilibri in steady state
so it certainly is um meant to speak
21st century physics are not the um the
thermodynamic equilibria that you would
have in in say a closed system so it's
all about how something say an observer
is open to the thing that is it is
observing and understanding um the
statistics of that exchange with the
thing that is it is open say for example
a heat bath it's understanding how you
couple to a heat Bath and Beyond and
what certain properties would um that
coupling and the system say The Observer
of that heat path would possess if it
were the case technically that this um
joint system had a pullback attractor so
it's largely framed around the notion of
random dynamical systems but it does
assume that there exists a pullback
attractor to which the system is being
attracted um so most of the
um most of the free energy principle
would really only apply over the time
scale that you are circulating on that
attracting set so if at a certain time
scale there would could be um reasonably
assumed over a period of time uh and on
equilibrium steady state then you can
apply the the free energy principle so
that you at that level it there are
assumptions about persistence um and you
know I I know that you make a big thing
about the way that we measure and
observe the universe rests upon that
sort of notion of things having temporal
persistence I I guess that the same kind
of commitment is inherent in assuming
that there is a non-equilibrium steady
state solution to the Dynamics you in in
a classical uh in a classical
formulation so so so I mean you you're
you're really talking about if the world
isn't changing too much this is what
brains and things like them are going to
be trying trying to achieve that is
they're going to be trying to set things
up so that they can you know as as well
as possible predict what's going to
happen so I'm I'm kind of curious
whether you see that as being an
inevitable feature of sort of our
success in the struggle for life in
biological evolution and whether you
think it's kind of almost a corollary to
uh kind of a a a a a brain oriented
corollary to sort of success in natural
selection or whether you think it has a
different kind of
origin um I would look at Natural
Selection as
one manifestation of exactly the same
kind of self-organization but at a much
slower time scale so um success just is
existing and existing is um maintaining
yourself in some characteristic states
that you can be identified as that kind
of thing over a certain time period so
if that is Success then um the free
energy principle is just uh describing
the necessary properties from the point
of view of of a classical physicist or
at least somebody uh um framing things
in terms of um random dynamical systems
success just is existing for or
persisting for a sufficient amount of
time and that could be um at a time
scale uh suitable to understand um your
organization of a single cell so that
the persistence would actually you know
possibly be in hours to weeks to months
or it could be the kind of persistence
you might bring to the table to
characterize or Define the
characteristic Co grain states that
apply to a particular species for
example and then you'd be looking at
Evolution as a process of um effectively
finding those phenotypes that persist um
there's a lot of phologies here which
perhaps if you just indulge me so the
surprise we're talking about is just the
self-information in a shones sense
that's just a negative log probability
of you know me as something um being in
in a particular state so in minimizing
that
self-information I'm also implicitly
maximizing the probability of me
occupying this particular state so I'm
just maximizing my marginal likelihood
having marginalized out all the
environmental or external causes of the
exchange with the environment so read in
that way it's just you could also say it
is a statement of adaptive Fitness at an
evolutionary set in an evolutionary
sense that it is a measure of the
probability you will find something like
me in this particular Eco Niche so then
you can now start to read Evolution
natural selection as basian model
selection in the sense that um a basian
sta ICI would just select the best
hypothesis or the best model of her data
on the basis of the marginal likelihood
or the evidence for that model so that
leads to a nice picture of evolution is
effectively um Nature's way of doing Bas
in model selection trying to get the
right kind of model for this kind of
econ Niche I mean clearly things get a
little bit more complicated when the the
model is starting to build that econiche
but in essence that you know that that's
a sort of um the deflationary aspect of
this description you know it's
just yeah but but I mean so I'm kind of
curious in in an an organism it's trying
to make its world as predictable as
possible by by getting smarter as an
organism and by giving itself you know
an easier house to live in where it
doesn't have to be subject to the
vicissitudes of nature so to speak where
it can it can just uh uh you know have a
predictable life but I suppose you know
maybe it seems very kind of um uh sort
of every day to say I
mean if that that's kind of like you're
setting things up to make things as
status quo as possible because that's
that's the case in which things will be
as as predictable as possible but yet
some of us perhaps even like you and me
like going to explore things where we
don't kind of know what's going to
happen and uh so I'm I'm sort of curious
how you see kind of unexpected
scientific discovery in the context of
kind of a a model of what what in a
sense brains try to achieve in in so far
as you you're you're positing that uh
sort of things should be set up to be as
predictable as possible how does kind of
going out and finding surprising things
in in science or nature fit into that
I'm I'm sort of curious right well it's
interesting you end the question with
curious because that that that would be
the answer wouldn't it you how would you
explain us as curious creatures so from
from the the physicist point of view um
this rests um on the um the picture of
the free energy Principle as simply a
principle of least action so it's it's
um uh
you know there is some time integral in
play uh exactly of the kind that sort of
Richard F and just to explain where the
free energy comes from in this sense it
is exactly the kind of free energy
Richard fan used to um is elude the
intractable problem of marginalizing
over all possible paths but providing a
variational bound on that marginal uh
that marginal or the log of the uh the
marginal likelihood uh which is has been
used to great effect in statistics um
and indeed um you defines a whole field
of variational Bays so it is purely um
an information theoretic probabilistic
quantity that bounds the the the
marginal likelihood but crucially um it
applies to trajectories and paths so I
think that's the solution to your um I
think very natural and challenging
question why is it if we are surprised
is minimizing we act in a way that is um
information seeking that responds to
novelty to response to sensation and
indeed as you say you both and I you and
I now are engaging in this sort of
uncertainty res resolving curiosity
driven kind of behavior and one could
also cast both our lives as doing
exactly this and our and Keith and Tim
that's the whole raise on Detra of the
of these of these interviews that's to
um gain information you celebrate
information seeking Behavior you the The
Narrative answer to your question that
if you're trying to minimize
surprise and you want to use that
principle to understand the kinds of
paths that I would choose or elect to
take through some State space then I'm
going to try to choose those or I am
more likely to choose those paths that
minimize expected surprise now if you
remember expected surprise is just Ed
self information so that's just
uncertainty so entropy so I will in
terms of the path that I take in terms
of my behavior my choices and my actions
over time then I am more likely to
choose those actions that reduce uh the
entropy of my beliefs or my measurements
namely reduce my uncertainty so that's
that that is if you like the kernel of
the application of the free energy
principle not just the states of mind
but to the way that one can understand
agency in the sense of your how do um
sentient things or things that could be
cast as observing in some sense how did
they behave or how must they behave if
they on average minimize the path
integral of their surprise or the bound
abound upon surprise so red light that
it is just a statement it's just you A
variation of principle of least action
that now acquires an
interpretation that you end up saying
well I am then if I exist and I am an
agent that that can act upon that world
and can gather the right kind of data or
sample the right uh the right um sensory
inputs or sensory exchanges with that
world then it will look as if I am
curious and you're perhaps your we um
mankind or womankind is you're the
epitome of that kind kind of
self-organizing realization of that
principle of of least action does that
I'm not quite understanding this so I
mean in in uh
uh in the traditional path and GL
physics one has what one is trying to
minimize is the action effectively the
relativistically invariant uh kind of um
uh
energy uh quantity and one when
specifically one's trying to you know uh
find well actually it's not necessarily
minimized find the extrema of e to the I
times the action where
So you you're I mean you know there's a
there's a there's a fairly specific uh
kind of concept in physics of of how
that works that rather spectacularly in
our kind of models ofun FAL physics we
can actually derive from much lower
level computational Concepts but I think
that's not really where you're going
with what you're thinking about I think
instead what you're thinking about is
you have a a path integral
of if if I'm if I'm not mistaken you
you're saying there is sort of the life
of the organism is the the the time
variable and the life of the organism is
what you're integrating over and the
possible paths correspond to the
possible things the organism could do
somehow navigating through what is some
kind of distribution space of of of
probabilities um is is that roughly
right or did I did I totally
misunderstand that no know I think it is
certainly roughly right the rightness
there is that
you well first of all
um the sort of formal the pathal
formulation the free energy principle is
he is just exactly finding that path
that that minimizes that that um the
integral of the um this variational free
energy but you also right that the
variational free energy is a functional
of a probability distribution so the
twist here is that the physical states
of an observer that is somehow
identifiable or individuate or separable
from the thing that is that is uh being
observed stand in for the sufficient
statistics or the parameters of
probability distributions conditional
probability distributions you know um
interpreted or read as Basin beliefs of
a very subpersonal sort so this free
energy is a function of a function it's
a function of probability distributions
that are parameterized by the physical
paths that your internal States internal
to The Observer would take and then the
game is to try and find or um for
certain particles that have very very
precise internal Dynamics they will
follow the path of least action in a
standard classical physics sense and but
in this instance you would be
interpreting that as um um paths that
are um described in terms of the
smallest variational Fe energy
functional of the beliefs encoded by
those paths so if those um if that free
energy is now read in terms of a measure
of or representation of the internal
States sorry the external States um then
what you're saying is this this path of
least action is effectively the path of
least surprise about what you think is
actually causing the your your exchange
with the external States so the twist
here is that you're you're work you're
making a distinction well the move from
say um physics or the move which makes
the uh the physics that um is described
by the free energy principle distinct
from usual applications of of the pathal
formulation is that you've got a
distinction between the states an
observer and that which is observed
which now allows or licenses you um to
interpret the observing States as
holding beliefs about the observed
States so um under you know what we um
would normally call a sort of Markoff
blanket partition where you're
partitioning the uh all possible States
into the states of the thing doing the
observation and the thing and the
external States being um being observed
what you're saying is that the internal
States now play the role of the
sufficient statistics of beliefs or
distributions about the external States
so these are beliefs about something
they're not the probability distribution
of the thing itself which is you know
what you would apply or um how you
deploy it the princip deploy the
principal least action uh in the usual
sense but it's the same exactly the same
math but now applied to the the
conditional distributions or the basing
beliefs encoded by or entailed by the
internal States so this is where the
sort of the physics of sence comes in
and you can start to talk about being
surprised you in an anthropomorphic
sense um but the maths is is you know
there's there's nothing new in the math
it's just it's just um what inherits
from being able to distinguish between
the inside and and the outside does that
make sense so you're moving on let me
see if I understand that so so let's
take a a sort of an initial simplified
model where we don't consider the
internal states of the Observer at all
let's just start with an observer
hanging out in an environment and uh
choosing a path through in a sense
through that environment so imagine that
the environment is parameterized by
let's
say an an information amount or an
entropy the the the environment is
parameterized by different let's say
we've just got a plane XY plane for
example and at every point in the XY
plane we have a certain amount of Random
some places in the XY plane are very
predictable we can just you know there's
a road that's just very well defined and
if we go off the road we're in this kind
of billowing area where all kinds of
random things are happening so my
understanding would be that that in your
principle if we don't start talking
about the internal states of the
Observer that what your principle would
say is follow the road follow the thing
that's predictable don't go off into
those billowing um outside side areas
where there's much more Randomness in in
the uh in the behavior I mean that would
be if I understand correctly and that
would sort of minimize that would make
things as predictable as possible
because you're just going down the road
you're not you're not subjecting
yourself to the to the to the other
Randomness in the environment so we
start with that now you start to say
well I don't just want to talk about the
external environment I want to talk
about also the internal states of the
Observer and how the Observer builds up
some view of the environment um and and
builds up their own model of what's
going on and let me see if I can
untangle that I mean so so first of all
am I am I more or less right in terms of
thinking about in the pure fixed
Observer external environment The
Observer will pick the predictable Road
not the unpredictable areas of
Randomness is is that is that kind of
the right Intuition or well I wonder if
if I can just jump in here for second if
you don't mind and and kind of
formulate cuz I've been thinking about
this a lot you know since we've been
talking to you uh professor friston and
I think this road right so we have this
2D landscape and there's there's really
a narrow path I think is is the idea
because hey the universe is complicated
life is complicated there's lots of fire
and brimstone you know kind of all over
the place and really the path that leads
to you continuing to exist is quite a
narrow needle that you need to thread
and if I understand correctly in order
to thread that needle in order to even
stay on the path you have to be able to
model the landscape a bit at least
sufficiently well that you can stay on
the path because most actions actually
lead you off into the the billowing
chaotic area where you're likely to say
have your cell membrane disrupted you
know if you're if you're a cell and so
that therefore if you're going to
continue to stay on this path of of
survival you must in some way at least
partly sufficiently well enough model
this landscape in order to stay on the
path is this is this correct I I I think
to me that that that sounds like a clear
way to think about it given I mean
particularly if the landscape is
changing then it is necessary then then
some purely inertial activity of just
I'm going to keep going in a straight
line isn't going to cut it and you know
so that sort of necessitates some kind
of internal uh you know learning on the
part of the Observer I mean
the and and I I suppose in in this
thinking about so what attributes does
the Observer have to have so that
um so that it can be successful for
example would you imagine that if the
world was too unpredictable a place if
physics was I mean is this a fact of
physics that the world is predictable
enough that an observer
who can sort of continue to exist is
possible I mean this is something which
I think from from my understanding of of
fundamental physics one of the things
that is not obvious is that an observer
who persists in time is possible in the
universe that's almost an assumption of
uh kind of the way that one can derive
the laws of physics that we see from
sort of underlying computational
foundations is that it is possible to
have an observer who persists in time so
I'm I'm curious with with with with your
setup uh Carl what what um uh you know
could you imagine a world in which the
uh I mean you might say well whatever
the world is like there's always going
to be something which follows this
minimum principle of uh of of minimizing
maximizing predictability but you know
maybe there is Maybe maybe there's a
question of whether there could be a
world in which you can never achieve a
decent level of predictability um and in
which I mean perhaps there's a different
thing to ask which is okay you predict
what's going to happen but I mean for
example you know the control system the
the autopilot that's flying the plane
can predict what's going to happen but
if there's a great big vacuum in the air
the plane is is toast you know whatever
prediction it might make it might say
hey I want to you know move the aerons
in this way and that way but if the
plane's just going to drop by 500 ft
it's going to be toast whatever goes on
so I'm I'm sort of curious what uh you
know do you imagine that there's some
kind of limit to you know there's
there's some domain of
controllability uh that the world exists
in a domain of controllability or do you
think that there's sort of uh that kind
of a brain can learn anything so to
speak or I mean I'm curious how you
think about
that um I think that brains are very
privileged and unique and that I would
imagine there are there are parts of the
universe or there are universes in which
this kind of thing could not exist um so
I think that we're very rare things um
we have attained um some degree of um
non-equilibrium steady state with our
particular environment which I suspect
is a a very rare kind of um parents um
and that that very existence the
emergence of an
observer is would manifest to us and
indeed does manifest to us as a kind of
intelligence a kind of sentience that
may or may not have some kind of deep
planning uh associated with it but these
I would imagine are very rare instances
um and if I you know had to qualify why
why are they so rare um the they depend
upon a very very um sparse and
structured dependencies amongst amongst
the states in question and the states in
question here would be the states of the
the universe or the niche and in
particular the that subset of states
that constitute The Observer so the
Observer cannot is you know um very much
as I imagine you in the way in your
physics project the The Observer is part
of the system so we just have a joint
distribution Over All possible States
and there are certain patterns of
interactions and certain states that you
can associate with an observer in some
very very rare instances and then under
the free energy principle at least for
me the Deep question then is well how do
you then Define that subset of states
and in so doing can you say anything
about the relationship between the sub
set of states that constitute The
Observer and remaining states that are
that are that are being observed the
only things you can say well let's put
this another way um so that puts
pressure on the definition of the subset
of states that constitutes something or
some some Observer um and you're at the
end of the day you um I end up or we end
up um saying well okay we have to be
able to um
identify the states of
something um in a way that allows us to
disambiguate or not confuse it um or not
exchange it with the states of
everything else and that usually relies
upon in you know um in the classical
formulation of the Fe um it relies upon
specifying sparse coupling sparse
dependencies so if one imagines um
um go some kind of universe where there
um there are lots of um um States um or
locations that can have occupy different
states then you're now talking about a a
universe that is essentially or parts of
this universe that are essentially empty
of connections so you're resting upon
the assumption that there are there are
there
exists pockets of the universe where
there are sufficient sparcity of
dependencies and and neighborhood
interactions
that permit the emergence of this
separation between say the inside of
something and the outside of something
when that is in play then the free
energy principle uh principle applies
even our in our own Universe shortly
after the big bang we wouldn't expect
there to be this type of of life because
the universe wasn't by that point sparse
is that is that essentially what you're
saying I think so I think that's what's
being said I mean I I think I think that
you know in a sense what you're saying
is the Observer is a persistent thing
and in order to be persistent it better
not be being bashed too hard by things
from the outside world there better be
some way in which the Observer is only
sparsely coupled to the outside world so
the Observer can have a coherent
identity that is persistent in some way
now obviously there are things that are
persistent you know your average little
black hole is fairly persistent um and
uh you know so is your average electron
or Photon propagating through
through you know through empty space so
to speak or the vacuum whatever that uh
which isn't that empty actually um but
uh uh so you know this so I think I
think what as I understand it your
notion of an observer which by the way
is is kind of similar to my notion of an
observer would be that um it is a thing
which has a certain coherence and
persistence and it has certain internal
States and I think I think part of what
you're describing
is the way in
which you know you have a a more
complicated feedback loop than perhaps
uh than I've really thought that much
about a complicated feedback loop where
the Observer is kind of building their
own world both in terms of their model
of what's happening in the outside world
and the part of that outside world in
which the Observer is choosing to live I
mean the Observer is hanging out on the
surface of the Earth and isn't going and
flying to the Sun and uh you know
sticking themselves in a um in a you
know 10 million degree furnace so to
speak and um
that and so there's I mean this question
first question I suppose
is and and by the way when it comes to
physics this question about persistence
is there's even more basic questions
like is pure motion possible you know
what is motion motion is you've got a
thing and it can move to other places
but it's not obvious that when you move
the thing that it is still the same
thing and that's something we're very
familiar with because but you know for
example if we live near A Spacetime
Singularity we might not even believe in
pure motion because near A Spacetime
Singularity your average you know coffee
cup or something will be so distorted
that it's not clear you would still
identify it as that same coffee cup so
to speak so I I think in in um uh it's
kind of the nature of of physics that
we're used to is is one where it is
possible to have pure motion it's
possible to have persistence at that
level but I think what you're I
mean you
know what I I I've been interested in in
trying to
characterize what our observers like us
like and the the thing in our physics
project that's really the the kind of
the the sort of motivation for that
is that there is this thing we call the
ruad this kind of entangled limit of all
possible computations which is in a
sense has everything in it
and to know what things we will perceive
to actually be in the universe that we
experience we have to kind of know how
we're going to be doing that
experiencing and that forces us to
understand something about us as
observers and so it is interesting quite
interesting as far as I'm concerned to
try and get a better characterization of
what observers like us are like and I
think for me two critical features of
obs observers like us are that we are
computationally bounded we have sort of
only finite Minds we can't untangle
every detail of what might be happening
in the universe we can only look at sort
of aggregated uh large scale features um
and that's one thing and the second
thing is that we at least believe we're
persistent in time we believe that even
though we might structurally be made
from different atoms of space at
successive moments of time
we we can imagine that we have a
persistent experience of the universe so
to speak so I think what you're and and
I'm very those two conditions are
sufficient to allow us to derive second
law of
Thermodynamics general relativity and
quantum mechanics which I think is
absolutely spectacular because the fact
that those things could be derivable
from some underlying principle is is
really remarkable to me but it's my
suspicion that if we knew more about
what we are inevitably like as observers
that we will be able to derive more of
the way that we that the Universe seems
to us so for example uh something I was
just realizing today actually in
connection we just had a lovely little
simulation that we made of two little
black holes in our model of SpaceTime uh
merging and one of the things that's
really dramatic in that simulation is
how much activity there is in the
background of space that is that space
in order to exist has to have a lot of
activity just to knit together the
different pieces of space independent of
having the black hole there and that
sort of as as one tries to think about
what one is seeing in that video One
realizes that another thing about
observers like us is we kind of believe
that we are at a fixed place in space it
is not necessary that in other words in
in general relativity for example we
could have a coordinate system where
we're moving around all over the place
in space but one of the things that
again is one of our assumptions I think
implicit perhaps assumptions of
observers like us is that we think we're
at a fixed place in space I was kind of
realizing that that's sort of why cernus
was so shocking so to speak because you
know we really did believe we were at a
fixed place in space because that is our
experience and yet you know if if the
Earth's going around the Sun that can't
really be what's actually happening in
some sense but but I I think so what I'm
trying to understand is in in your sort
of view of uh kind of characteristics of
observers I think you're you're
describing sort of a more nuanced
version of what an observer like us has
to be like and this kind of seeking of
predictability is it's an interesting
idea I mean it it's um uh and the
question would be you know to what
extent in this kind of you know unruly
ruad so to speak of all possible
computations that we are seeking the
predictable paths or or the predictable
sort of seeking predictability in that
is is sort of an interesting principle I
mean I suppose I'm
curious if you look at
it from the point of view
of
uh well I I think as you say it's a
little bit torical because um you know
without
predictability if things are
sufficiently unpredictable you don't get
to coherently exist if things are
sufficiently unpredictable you will be
torn apart by those outside forces that
you cannot control so to speak um I I am
curious uh you know when it comes to
things like control theory and you know
the the whole sort of idea of uh you
know I mean control theory is a is a
much more limited way of thinking about
what can you control but I'm sort of
curious in
um I mean if if I were to try to let's
say my
environment
was
uh
some well how unpredictable an
environment can I be in and still
achieve enough control to be your kind
of Observer I guess I I would be curious
if there's a characterization of just
how unruly can the world
be and still
allow a a coherent Observer of the kind
that you're you're
imagining that's um yeah that's a
challenging question your a superficial
answer was not that unruly there has to
be something uh recognizable As Time
proceeds can I just say you you brought
so many wonderful issues to the table
there all of which I can see through the
lens of my understanding of the much
simpler and classical physics that that
um underwrites you know the free energy
principle you know um just very briefly
this um these two fundaments that that
you mentioned the notion of
computational
boundedness plus persistence in time
underwriting thingness and in particular
your the capacity to just observe or be
an observer um for me um that is
immediately reflected in the uh the two
pillars of the free energy principle
which is first of all a Markoff boundary
which is the thing that demarcates the
Observer from from The observed so I
know that you were using bounded in a in
a your sort of bounded rationality
possibly or comp yeah different sense
but um you I still think it's quite
beautiful that in fact the whole Fe can
just be written down from the statement
there exists a Markoff boundary that
separates the inside of a thing from the
outside of a thing um and if you can I
actually can I pick up on that for a
second because I'm really curious about
um you know to me for example our
sensory
organs are presumably there's a brain
inside but it's connected only by
certain sort of thin sensory organs to
the outside world
and I guess that I'm I'm curious because
to me what sensors what our sensors and
our measuring devices typically do is
they take a large number of possible
things that might be happening in the
world the equivalents a lot of those
together so we just get to say I see a
cat even though the details of the
pixels in that cat might be very
different and I'm sort of curious to the
extent that you talk about this kind
kind of Markov boundary Markov blanket
idea um to what extent is the is the
sparsification
of external
stimuli for that same reason that is
that that it seems like measuring
devices or our senses you know
whatever their big purpose is take all
these different possible states of the
world and equivalence lots of them
together so that we can just make a
simple summary is that consistent with
your kind of view of how how you get
that sparsity of connection between the
outside and the inside so to speak or do
you have a different point of view about
that no no I I have exactly that point
of view and I'd even go further you the
all the internal machinations on the
inside which of course you will never
see because it's hidden behind the
markof blanket you observing The
Observer will only actually ever see the
behavior the active states of that
markof blanket um and the impression of
the environment on that sensory
epithelia or those sparse sensory
sampling those measurement tools um but
beyond that the whole point um so one
key way of reading the uh maximization
of marginal likelihood or the basically
the the likelihood of these sensory
Impressions under a model of um what
caused those um sensory um Impressions
that is under the hood um is to say you
want the um the most accurate
explanation that is as simple as
possible so literally the you the log
marginal liklihood is equal to accuracy
minus complexity so you're in the game
of compression you're in the game of cor
graining that is an emergent property of
maximizing the marginal likelihood of
your sensory exchanges with with with
the observed so um this I think notion
of course graining is absolutely Central
here at many many different levels you
know and you know um that's that's what
I want to ask about is because this is a
connection that that Tim and I have been
thinking about to the being
computationally bound is that if you're
a computationally bound Observer you
necessarily must compress even if your
sensory organs could perceive every
every particle within you know your your
your light light cone it still wouldn't
do you any good because you don't have
the computational capacity to compute
right you you to compute all that you
only have a finite amount so therefore
you almost necessarily have to do
something like the free energy principle
because you've got a compress which
implies uncertainty and inaccuracy and
therefore you need to balance out how
accurate can I be with the with the
amount of computation that I can do um
you know with my my resources but so
there's a there's a little bit of a
difference here because you know you
could imagine something where there's
lots of Random
romness which you just ignore for
purposes of your sensory
input but I think what's being said
about this free energy principle is
that you're you're doing more than just
ignoring it you are actively trying to
lead your life so as to minimize it
which is a different thing I mean you
could say we're going to observe uh you
know there's there's something happening
in I don't know uh uh
some we're exposed to a cloud let's say
we're exposed to all kinds of turbulence
in the air and we could say you know
we're perfectly happy we're exposed to
that but the only thing we're going to
pay attention to is something about how
you know light travels through the air
or something but but you're saying that
no actually we our way of leading Our
Lives consistent with our continued
existence so to speak is avoid that
turbulence go and you know go and you
know go and fly through sort of uh uh
unurban still air so to speak so that we
avoid the places where we are going to
be challenged by not knowing what's
going to happen so I I think you're
you're you're going Beyond just
saying we sort of throw
away
uh we throw away information you're
saying we actively seek to build a world
or to to organize ourselves to live in a
world where uh where things are as
predictable as possible and and as we
were saying I mean you know there might
come a time when sort of things become
deeply unpredictable and where there is
isn't and I assume that that I don't
know whether this is included in your
model but you know if suddenly something
very different happened if suddenly you
know the Earth went near a black hole or
something and all kinds of crazy things
started happening and and we don't know
what's going on there's presumably even
the process of figuring out what should
we do is is one that could take us a
while and I don't know whether that's
accounted for in your in your kind of
model of things I mean to say we go to
the the thing that minimizes our
surprise maximizes our predictability it
still could be there could be a
non-equilibrium phase in which we don't
even know it's very hard for us to work
out what will be the most predictable
path so to speak yeah radical
uncertainty if you're an economist yeah
absolutely uh you you're bringing again
so many issues at for it's difficult to
know what what to pick up on but I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm just I'm you're
getting me to think you know this is um
you're getting me to do the thing that
is precisely seems to be moving away
from the predictable path but but please
please go on well much more fun yeah um
but in fact let's just take that phrase
moving away from the predictable path um
because it's got moving in I think
that's quite crucial so you know one
could um and I I have to confess I'm
using um the word Observer deliberately
to to try and get you to talk about your
notion of observer in the context of the
ruad um generally I just say something
so so a thing um um just exists but if a
thing moves and this speaks exactly to
what you were talking about before it is
more than just passively um assimilating
sensory information sensory samples from
the world and compressing them in some
good way as a good statistician would
would do and then just forming the right
kind of coar grained model or compressed
model as people like y smid Huber would
would would emphasize or uh indeed um
you know the whole um formulation of
efficient Communication in terms of
minimum message length and minimum
description length formulations you know
the the the the kind of universal
computation you get to from KRA
complexity all of this is about making
sense of stuff from the outside coming
in but of course when you're moving
exactly as you say you've now got the
opportunity to decide what sensory
information to go and gather or you can
change your perceived or modeled
external States in order to deliver
different kinds of information and I
think that's that's the twist that's
what makes an observer an observer as
opposed to just um you know a cile
object or a passive thing that is not
able to actually change the course can
act back upon um use the word feedback I
think that's absolutely crucial so
there's a circular causality here
certain kinds of things certain an
observer I think a true agential
Observer has the capacity to act upon
the thing that's generating the data and
it is in that in that acting that you
get the Curiosity and as you say
ignoring and in fact actively avoiding
that noisy ambiguous potentially
boundary
destroying um dissipative um part of the
universe and sticking to those paths but
in sticking to those paths because you
can't see the paths as they unfold deep
into the universe all you have are the
sensory Impressions that are local to
your local interactions on your s on
your obser your your measurement um uh
tools or your sensory receptors so you
actually have to have a model of what
might be going on and where the path
might be leading in order and of course
that's where this resolution of
Uncertain the Curiosity comes in that
you're taking all the local cues to
build a model of where you think the
path might be so that you can follow the
path so to come right back to your final
thing what happens if we went too close
to a black hole could we think our way
out of it I think we possibly could in a
sort of um science fiction sense simply
because we've got the right kinds of
models of our lived World which is just
the physics that you're talking about
but lots of other observers would not be
able to do that unless they had that
right kind of internal model that
implicit um way of modeling the causes
of uh all of my
Sensations maybe maybe we should maybe
we should address that point a little
bit I mean the question of what can be
an observer I mean I think you were
talking about thingness so to speak
which is a lower bar probably than
Observer I mean thingness might just be
the ability to maintain an independent
object maintain something that we can
consider to be a persistent object yes I
have to say I think that's a that's a
complicated concept right there because
let's say we've got an Eddie in a fluid
for example is that a persistent object
well it seems that way to us but at the
level of molecules it's not a persistent
object at the level of molecules it's
different molecules making it up at
every moment in time but like the Great
Red Spot on Jupiter same thing or the
Eternal Flame or a hurricane all these
quite annoying vague boundaries right
but I mean but it's only two a coar
graining Observer measurer like us that
that thing seems persistent yes to it
itself you know if if that thing was uh
if if we were molecules we would say no
it passed us right by it's it's no
longer we're no longer part of that
thing so I mean I guess I'm I'm curious
in um I mean that so I claim
thingness is well I'm I'm wondering to
to what
extent
thingness is the same as
Observer and you know to to identify
something as a thing it needs to be
perceived as having certain persistance
to whatever is observing it and
also I suspect it has to be bounded the
the the the sort of the amount of stuff
in the thing has to be bounded in other
words if the thing is the whole universe
you don't get to call it a thing it's
only a thing if it's of limited you know
if it's a limited part of the whole so
to speak um but I I guess I'm
curious um you have this point of view
that two things I think that are
implicit one is that an observer like
thing has some kind of free will about
about what it can do that is the The
Observer can by
choice explore this versus that it's not
a question of just the vortex is moving
through the fluid and the laws of motion
make it do this or that thing I mean and
I think this is um so so you're
attributing to the thing that you are
treating as an observer some degree of
possibility of choice
and although maybe maybe not maybe
you're saying that your free energy
principle is essentially the
deterministic physics of what has to
happen and even though the Observer may
feel that they have a choice they really
ultimately have no choice um because
they're really being you know led by the
nose so to speak by this free energy
principle to do what they do and even
though they might imagine that they
could do something different they
necessarily won't do something different
I mean I'm I'm I'm curious what you see
as being I mean does does your
notion of I mean are you saying that
okay so so one point of view would be
that what you're describing is kind of a
law of motion
for for an observer and that that law of
motion despite the Observer feeling that
they can choose to do this or that they
really can't any more than you know an
object moving inertially through space
can choose to do this or that so like
like for example you got a spacecraft
and it's got all kinds of Critters
inside it and they're running around and
they're saying we got to do this and
that and the other but their spacecraft
without any propulsion system is just
going to keep going in this inertial
trajectory whatever they might you know
they might run around and and and uh
have all kinds of enthusiasm for things
it might do but it's not going to do
them any good um and so you might take
the point of view that that it's the
same thing with our brains and I'm
curious whether whether you do take that
point of view well I love that analogy
of the you the spacecraft with lots of
intelligent sentient Critters that can't
actually control where they're going um
I again you've picked up I think on some
key points there um so I would say that
to be an observer is to have the kind of
agency that you're implying by the count
choosing or selecting certain actions to
uh to commit to actions on the world
that will uh elicit or solicit different
kinds of measurements that you can then
use make sense Ed to make sense of your
model of how um the you know the world
works and your place and the way that
you couple to that world so I I'd agree
absolutely entirely that there's there
is a bright line between this being a
thing being that Vortex or um um you
know soliton or uh some something that
just persists and um having the kind of
agency that allows you to plan and to
make moves and I think planning although
it's you not um perhaps a
very intuitive way of describing it
actually captures the notion that you
actually spoke to which is you know
having a choice means that you have
counterfactual beliefs in your model
about the consequences of your action I
think that's quite crucial I think that
introduces another bright line between
different kinds of things so there are
things that just don't act you know
there things possibly like the vortex or
a stone things that can't um couple back
and change their environment and then
there are things that can move back and
change their environment and you could
argue this um massive bodies might uh
might fall into this category by
exerting um so gravitational forces just
Open brackets I agree with you entirely
things like space and time these are
fantasies or hypotheses that only come
from this coar grained observation of o
o o of the world um but I think the key
line between the kind of Observer that
you and I are and the kind of
observations that say a thermostat would
do is exactly what you're talking about
it's it's you know imagining
counterfactual Futures and very simply
articulated mathematically by just um
subsuming one's own actions under the
inferred causes of your Sensations so
this slightly paradoxically says well I
can write down mathematically um this
free energy functional of a generative
model or a joint distribution over
causes and consequences the inside and
the
outside sorry the other way around the
outside and the
inside and I I can for certain kinds of
uh systems or things um actually include
the things actions in the causes so now
you've got this um mathematical image of
from the inside of an observer um of an
observer that has beliefs about what it
is doing which are completely separate
from what he's actually doing because
because it doesn't know what it's doing
until it senses the consequences of what
it has done so I think this is this
brings you to the you know a better
description of things that plan and it's
at this point then you get this
information seeking ambiguity avoiding
you talked about control in control
theory all of these good behaviors just
fall out of naturally the kinds of
behaviors that you'd expect if you apply
uh literally the variation principle of
least action to um a a a prob
distribution over not just the external
causes of what you're observing obing
but also your own cause your sort of um
autop poetically expressed causes
through through your actual action and
they they must be very special kinds of
very very sparsely connected things
because they're unaware of their own
action they can't sense their own
action so here's the thing that confuses
me so I I I I have the impression that
you spent lots of your career trying to
understand what happens inside brains
and in a sense you know presumably with
you know at some time in the future
we'll be able to measure every
significant feature of the kind of
neural firings that happen inside brains
and I'm curious then when your point of
view about counterfactuals and planning
and so on once we can see
deterministically this neuron fired it
caused this neuron to Fire and so on how
does that relate to your distinction
between the stone and the
Brain then you would be looking for
empirical evidence I should say that um
there's a slight Catch 22 here because
if you uh just come back to a notion you
you were you were um referring to
earlier on that there has to be some
sort of finite bound on the number
degrees of freedom that constitute the
internal states of an observer as
distinct from the the channels that are
doing the observing or the the control
channels that are you know the outputs
as it that are uh um um mediating the
action of of the observer in terms of
gathering her
data so you'd be looking for evidence
that the neuronal Dynamics were um or
the internal Dynamics had um could
plausibly be explained by a gradient
flow you a dis flow on this sort of free
energy landscape and you know what that
landscape is if you could find the right
generative model or the joint
probability distribution that stands in
for um the beliefs about implicit
subpersonal mathematical beliefs um
entailed by the structure and the
Dynamics of the internal States so in a
sense that's what I do as you know for
my day job um and indeed I suspect
that's what we all do day-to-day in
terms of trying to infer the people's
intentionality and states of mind you
know we're trying to work out what under
what kind of structure or belief
structure or generative model
um is the you are these um behaviors
intentions um
understandable if if I can jump in
because I've I've heard you talk about
this before in a slightly different way
which is essentially as soon as you're
performing a computation that's modeling
yourself you know as soon as you have
inside your brain a humulus if you will
that's that's able to watch a screen and
entertain these counterfactual
trajectories that you could or may or
may not take it's at that point once you
have that counterfactual depth I think
you referred to it both a counterfactual
and
temporal depth to your computation that
it's at that point that you have this
agency or the ability to you know choose
choose actions is that fair yeah and and
certainly that would be necessary to be
sort of self-aware to have a minimal
kind of selfness and to know that you
are you are an agent as well um could
argue that that that you could equip a
thermostat with you know a very
sophisticated generative model of the
consequences of turning the you know a
heating element on or off um and
introduce into that model uncertainty
sensitivity to initial conditions or
some kind of stochastic chaos and let it
plan you can and indeed we do we build
you know sort of artifacts that do have
a certain sense of planning they
wouldn't be know they wouldn't know they
were agents but they they would have a
certain kind of agency that would elude
any potential um Proactive or uh
anticipatory dynamics that you might
find in the stone so you're looking for
um you're looking for sort of um
conservative Dynamics your
divergence-free dynamics that have a
certain kind of
itinerancy um that you know normally
expresses itself in terms of
oscillations and life cycles or um you
know respirat Cycles or and the like so
you're looking for an itinerant kind of
dynamics that has the requisite variety
you know deliberately using Ross Ash's
um words that has the internal degrees
of freedom to be a good enough model of
the controllable aspects and the you
know the the um the modeled World which
is you know the internal the um the
stone or the uh the brain is actually
using to act upon the world uh and plan
to act upon the world
so I mean I think this is an important
potential distinction but I think it's
more complicated than this is my my
intuition so I mean let's take you know
considering our venue here of machine
learning Street talk let's talk about
AIS um you know we've got you know we've
got some artificial neural net it's uh
you know an llm is a fairly simple has a
fairly simple kind of flow of
information but imagine that we have
some some neuron net imagine that we
have taken our brains and you know we've
been so successful at Neuro Imaging of
some kind or whatever it is that we can
really pretty much map our brains onto
the the bit patterns of artificial
neural Nets now my question is I'm
looking at this bit pattern and I'm
asking myself does this bit pattern have
a model of
itself and one of the things that I
think is difficult in that is that any
universal computer is capable in some
sense of having a model of itself
because any universal computer is
capable of emulating any kind of
computational device including in
particular this the very computer that
is doing the emulating so I'm curious if
if if you're presented with you know the
bit pattern comes from you know
sophisticated Imaging of brains or
whatever or it comes from artificial
neuronet what is the what is the thing
that you put that into to make a
decision and and and you can't I think
consider you know all of
us have an internal feeling of how we
think things work and how we think we
work but we can't even other than by
extrapolation we can't even be sure that
other people other different human Minds
have the same point of view about what's
going on and so I'm curious from the
outside from a kind of pure you know
data science point of view I've got this
bag of bits and it's doing certain
things how do I tell whether this bag of
bits is meeting your Criterion of having
sort of a counterfactual planning model
of the world right um so much like um
the empirical problem and indeed the
hard problem of Consciousness you can't
um the whole point of the persistence
that we were talking about before red as
um the Persistence of of the boundary or
the Markoff blanket means you will never
know observing something what's going on
behind the markof planket it's
unknowable because if it were Noble or
measurable you'd have to destroy the
mark of planket and the thing in of
itself would not
exist uh and certainly if you think wait
a minute wait a minute I'm I'm not I'm
not assuming that I let's take let's
take the case that in an artificial
neural net we can look at every bit we
we don't happen to be yet
technologically able to do that for
brains but we can imagine I think a time
in which we can non-destructively look
at every bit of what's going on in the
brain and then the question is we're
seeing this complicated bit pattern
we're seeing it in artificial neuron net
which is easy to measure we're seeing it
in a brain which happens to be
technologically hard to measure right
now and then we're asking the question
is this pattern of bits that we're
seeing an example of something which is
a plausible sort of self-reflecting or
you know counterfactual generating
modeling the world internally kind of
thing or is it just a bag of bits that
follow certain
rules well I mean I think I think my
answer would be the same that you will
you will never know you you but you
could certainly infer that I mean I'm
smiling because you you're just
describing my day job again you know so
my entire life has been built around um
getting beneath the blanket and using
things like brain Imaging usually
noninvasive um but sometimes invasive
when you have to implant electrodes you
say for deep brain stimulation like and
and and measuring the internal Dynamics
the bits the patterns and the you know
the the computational architectures
implicit in the in the wiring and the
and and the um the neuron anatomy and
the connectone um and then making a best
guess and trying to infer is this the
kind of message passing or pattern or
updating or Dynamics or architecture
that could be explained in terms of a um
evidence maximizing free energy
minimizing belief updating process under
some kind of gentic model and if so what
kind of gen model is we quite a long way
with that I mean one of my favorite
examples is um you know brains like ours
have um this in distilled a fundamental
conditional Independence between
whatness and awareness into their
Anatomy so you know the top half of the
brain does all the awareness and does
all the uh the space or metric space you
specific pointing activity or looking
activity whereas the bottom streams of
the um in this instance the uh inferior
temporal lobe or the temporal lobe are
much more concerned with the whatness of
things and so you know there there are
certain um an architectural features of
both the Dynamics and the the
connectivity the sparity the coupling
that we were just talking about before
which give you strong Clues this is a
kind of generative model ah this kind of
person this kind of artifact clearly has
a generative model in which her lived
World entails things that objects that
might exist but knowing what something
it doesn't tell you where it is and vice
versa and immediately you think well
that's very consistent with my lived
world this metric world full of objects
you know physical or visual objects um
that can be in different places speaking
to your your very interesting example
before about um you know if I move
something is it the same thing well no
it's clearly not the same thing but you
know if you can sort of course grade and
factorize the world into whatness and
awareness and have some equivalance or
equivalence so well actually this is
like the same whatness but just now in a
different awareness so you've
partitioned statistically in your model
and the physical instantiation of that
model that um that sort of um
statistical regularity that that
persists even if the molecules of the
object don't persist but the regularity
the pattern the course grained
explanation for for for the sensory
Impressions generated by that thing you
put that into the anatomy so you you you
pursue that so what would you be looking
for if you've got some kind of agent
that has beliefs about the future and
then beliefs about itself having beliefs
about the future which I think is what
you're in implying um by the
self-modeling and You' be looking for a
high Hier archal structure you'd be
looking for um certain um Markoff
blankets or conditional independences
instantiated in the absence of literally
neuronal connections or wires on a bus
literally um a sparse coupling that had
a hierarchal aspect and and then you'd
be looking for the the correlates of the
message passing the amount of
electricity used for beyond that
particular
risk so your view is that it's kind of a
a serious The Watcher watching The
Watcher watching The Watcher type thing
and that in some sense I mean perhaps
your view is that sort of the the higher
cognitive function is literally a you
know a series of hierarchical levels
where you're sort of progressively
abstracting from the world that is at
some lowest level you've got the world
as it is and all those neuron you know
all those photons coming in all those
neuron firings happening at the first
level and then that you're somehow
progressively abstracting compressing
reducing that to eventually come to
presumably you know to the to the point
where you make a decision should I do
this or should I do that lots of lots of
sensory input has come in and you're
kind of filtering it down so I'm curious
if if you look at at uh you know other
animals not humans um do you imagine
that it's the same kind of I mean I mean
it's an interesting and quite
uh kind of I would say sort of it's a
it's a very definite view of of what it
means to be a thinking thing would be
that you're always taking all the
details of the world and always trying
to crush it down to the point where you
make a decision about what to do next
and that that would be a thing where you
could imagine uh observing that there's
all that compression happening to decide
what to do next now I I will say that I
don't think that's specific to brains I
mean imagine that you've got a rock it's
perched on some you know uh Hilltop or
something and lots of things happen to
the Rock there's rain there's wind
there's all kinds of things and
eventually one day the rock starts
rolling down the hill in other words
from all of those detailed from all
those details about what the Rocks the
environment that The Rock was exposed to
eventually it makes a definitive
decision and I I'm I'm curious what the
distinction is between that kind of sort
of many things happen and you know the
many things have to take place you know
the rock is eroded away and this happens
and that happens and it's a whole
hierarchy of actions and then eventually
one day the rock rolls down the hill so
how would you distinguish that from from
uh kind of your view of kind of the U
the sort of hierarchy of action in
brains I mean other than that in that
particular case the time scale might be
years in the case of the Rock and the
time scale for brains might be seconds
or something yes well that's a great
question a great challenge um so but
just to pick up on that that notion of
of of time scale um as soon as you have
a hierarchical um message passing scheme
or Dynamics or or physics of the kind
that I think we're talking about here
there's a separation of time scales as
you get hierarchically more abstract or
deeper if you like um into your Observer
um so part of the hierarchy will almost
inevitably entail a um the kind of
temporal persistence that you spoke
about earlier in terms of the observer
in reading her world as things that
endure over time including me uh
including our you ourselves um that is a
gift of the the Dynamics that usually
supervene at the deepest hierarchal
levels of any you imagine say
centripedal kind of hierarchy so I think
that's an important observation that you
you can't sort of commit to a single
time frame to understand the
contextualization of fast moving High
dimensional content in the course of the
course graining that there's also a
course graining over time which we call
context for example um so that would be
one important aspect when uh trying to
understand um could you call a rock
eventually being knocked from its perch
as a decision I would say probably not
because you haven't got the you the sort
of you know the scal inv variant over
time um it's certainly an event but You'
hardly call it an you know you could
hardly um call this uh any kind of
something that it persists over time you
know from my point of view it certainly
would not be an expression of a a
pullback attractor if the rock however
um fell down the hill and started
walking back up again that kind of
behavior would suggest to me ah there's
something going on of Interest under the
hood and I when I cracked the rock I'd
expect to see some high hierarchal
architecture and some itinerant dynamics
that would support that kind of
Separation separation of temporal scales
but before I sliced open the rock or put
you in a brain imager I wouldn't know
you know I just have to guess based upon
your behavior your your active state or
your your the the the boundary that
separates what's going on in your inside
from from me as part of your your
outside right but I mean the problem is
this is uh the well one will never know
is a reasonable thing to say on the
other hand if one's trying to make a
distinction between Observer like things
well this there's a couple of levels of
Distinction here there's the distinction
between just ever thing and things and
then things and observer like things and
I think the um um and I think several of
these distinctions are kind of
complicated and I'm I'm I'm
you know in order to have something
which seems like a a kind of a a
scientifically progressing kind of set
of ideas it seems like one really has to
be able to make a a definite distinction
between sort of
the know how do I tell from the bag of
bits that I have a an observer like
thing as opposed to just a thing and to
to kind of make that a bit more
technological uh you know we've got all
these AI systems and we've got everybody
talking about whatever they might mean
by AGI which I think is a kind of
foolish concept but that's a different
issue um and uh uh you know should one
imagine that uh the to make a more sort
of human agency like
AI that we necessarily have to have some
notion of Hier Hier Archy I mean you
know in in your average llm there is in
a sense one level of hierarchy in the
sense there's the feed forward of what
the llm does when it reach you know when
it tries to figure out the next token
and there's the kind of you know big
feedback loop of uh you know seeing the
previous tokens and then deciding what
to and and then uh uh sort of iterating
uh to to to to figure out what the next
token should be so I'm curious whether
you see whether you think that it's sort
of a fundamental idea of the way that
things like us work that there's a
deeper hierarchy and if you think that
that has implications for sort of the
technology of AI yes I I do I'm very
aware you're being very courteous you're
asking me questions all all the time
which is uh very generous of you H but
yes I I I think that that that that
hierarchal structure that I'm sorry I'm
just you see I'm I'm trying to I'm
trying to live
some version of your principle or not as
the case may be that I'm I'm doing a you
know seeking the unknown type thing yeah
but Keith and I please go ahead well
Keith and Tim promised me I'd learn all
about the rouard which I I I would I
would like to we won't have time now but
I would like to have pressed you on that
because yeah I find quite quite
intriguing um but we've we've now gone
into um um sort of you know large
language models and the kind of Dynamics
I think I think that's absolutely right
I think you I if I want let me put it
this way if I knew what the generative
model was I could actually just simulate
belief updating under that generative
model I could basically just integrate
under the P you know the principal least
action a free engine minimizing device
and it would look as if it was behaving
intentionally and planning and in a base
optimal way it would also do uh base
optimal K control it would do everything
you wanted if I could write down the
generative model but to write down the
generative model I have to know exactly
what kind of world what kind of user
what kind of ecosystem is this
particular computer designed for um and
furthermore I'd have to be able to
explain it you know so immediately
you've got if you give me a Compu if you
give me you know a piece of artificial
intelligence that is completely
explainable and by which I mean you can
write down the generative model and I
will understand it then yes I could tell
you exactly this is a stone this is
self-aware this is not self-aware but it
has a you know it still has a kind of
agency of a prospective sort this
thing's like a thermostat uh this thing
you know but but wait a minute once you
say you have a model that says
everything about what it does the thing
has no chance to have something that
anybody would consider to be something
like free will cuz you're basically
saying your you're you're stipulating
that the thing is just acts in a
predictable way yeah I guess maybe I'm
going to jump in here and say I don't I
don't think you need free will in order
to have agency so I think if I even if I
had a machine that was taking in inputs
and conducting an analysis and as a
result of that analysis deciding to
raise a red flag or you know walk up a
hill I still think that's agency even if
tell me what you mean by
agency what what I mean by that is is
literally that it's
performing a computation about sensory
inputs and as a result of that
computation deciding some some
output but so any old classifier any old
machine learning classifier does that
does it except it's not performing it's
not performing in in action though right
well it could be if you connect it to a
robot or something it can perform plenty
of actions and as soon as you do then it
then it becomes an then it becomes an
agent you know acting acting the world
okay so so I mean the the the you know
image identifying cat flap that decides
is it a cat or not that cat flap has
agency in your defin I I would say it
does it has a very simple form of agency
but I think that that's so so your
definition of agency is that there is
there are a large number of possible
inputs you are sort of you know
whittling that down to something about
which a decision can be made and then
you are actuating in the World perhaps
so for example does it have agency in
some environment yeah okay does it have
agency if the only thing it does is to
change a bit somewhere inside
itself in other words that bit might be
the bit that is on some iobs that causes
it to actuate the cat flap but that bit
might be at the beginning just an
internal bit inside in a sense the brain
of the AI so so how would you
distinguish those two things you say it
has to have that flow out to the outside
world in order to be validly an agent or
to have agency or can it have agency
with respect to so so for example can
there be a notion of agency if the end
result of your thinking is that you
think a particular thought is that
enough or does agency require actuation
in the real world yeah so I think the
way I the way I would frame it and look
this
to to both of you to uh to criticize it
or not but the way I would frame it is
if I'm affecting a change in the same
environment that I'm perceiving then I'm
an agent so it's like if I'm if I'm
taking an inputs from environment a okay
and then affecting a change in
environment B and A and B are totally
decoupled then I wouldn't call that
thing an agent that's something like a
bridge between two different two
different environments but as soon as I
can enact changes in the same
environment that I'm perceiving I think
that that's ordinarily what what a
person would perceive as being an agent
you know it could be very simple you
know roach a roach is an agent you know
maybe it has a very simple neural
circuitry but that assumes that there's
sort of an external environment and I
guess this relates to the whole Markoff
blanket business of whether you can
distinguish the outside environment
sparsely connected to your internal
States or whether you are you're merely
affecting so so you're saying if you've
got a gency so let me see if I
understand this there's sort of a sparse
connection from the outside world coming
in and that is you know there's a lot of
detail on the outside world there are
sparse connections coming into you and
you're saying you have agency if you can
back propagate so to speak not in the
sense of back propagation but if you can
if you can go back out through those
sparse connections to affect that big
complicated outside world then you say
you have agency that it requires this
sort of two-way thing that you're both
bringing it in through that sparse
connection and pushing it out through
the sparse connection is that is that
correctl I'm curious whether that's
whether you would agree disagree change
that um that that
definition I I was just relaxing see
that exchange
um um yeah I think you'd have to
acknowledge that there's I think twoo
distinct use of the words agency um you
know um I you know I can certainly um
argue for for um Keith's position that
simply being able to couple back and
complete that sort of circular causality
if I was a you talking to neurologists
this would be the action perception
cycle just being able to act upon the
world is one very simple definition of
an agent and that and that view of
thermostat would be would be you a kind
of
agent but the other the other sense I
think we we we've been using it as in a
slightly more Nuance sense which is the
um the ability to actively select a
particular course of action uh from a
number of counterfactual Alternatives
and that requires a much more expressive
kind of generative model so you know I I
I think that I'm not sure whether
they're bright lines um you could argue
that they're sort of vague or graded
distinctions would one way of thinking
about this is how far into the future do
you take your planning so if I'm a
thermostat I can just do that on sort of
you know first and second temporal
derivatives I can sort of you know like
a c filter
sorry um like the kind of linear
quadratic control that you would get if
you inter control or something P perfect
just a few derivatives in the moment um
that will give me um the kind of agency
that is very reflexive and autonomic and
automatic and the kind of thing that we
you know you could that could in
principle be found in autopilots and
thermostats and you know many things
that we use around the house um you
could argue that just by having those um
those um State estimates and their
higher derivatives that there is a sort
of future pointing aspect because you
can just sort of project out the path
you you lose uncertainty very quickly
but you can certainly sort of think of
those um those higher derivatives of say
the coefficients of a tailor expansion
of little path into the
future but so think you know what you at
what point though do you do do you go
into the future um sufficiently far that
you can call it a plan so at what point
and perhaps it there isn't a hard answer
perhaps it's just a graded it's just a
question of how tall are you how deep is
your temporal Horizon um and how your
deep can you infer it given this Anatomy
given the structure of the thermostat
and the or the um the time rollouts in a
you know in say you so I'm curious if if
you've got your average AI llm whatever
else and I go and I can probe that
system what do I look for to look for
planning and counterfactual the
construction of counterfactuals in other
words I've got I've I've read out a
trillion bits from my llm in action how
can I tell if it's thinking
counterfactually right first of all you
could just you do do what any life
scientist will do which is basically
either kill it and disect it and and
look at it look at its Anatomy or ping
it in some way and try to infer its
causal architecture
or let it run uh in its Naturals
environment and then look for
correlations measuring the functional
connect you know the do structural
equation model or or right I mean in the
case of an llm you know yeah it's just a
bag of bits on my computer I know what
every bit is there's no sort of you know
inference by no complicated inference I
know the bits the question is even given
those bits you know at the low lowest
level of bits I know what it is if you
ask me at a at a coarser level what is
it thinking for example I probably don't
have a clue because I don't have a way
to uh you know I don't have an you know
it seems like one of the key problems of
Neuroscience we don't have a way to
describe and perhaps this is what you're
you're working towards you know we don't
have a way to describe how brains work
at an intermediate level between kind of
the neuron firing
and the words that get spoken by the
brain type thing in other words that
that um um and so in the case of you
know the AI the llm whatever else I'm
curious because that's a case where we
don't have any limitation on the
underlying data we know what every bit
is and so now my question is can I run
what test would I run what kind of
correlation would I measure what kind of
what would I do to say hey you're a
counterfactually thinking Ai and this
one over here you know you could have a
a counterfactuality index or something
for different llms of how
counterfactually can they think how
would you measure that I I'm sorry I
keep on asking questions but I'm just
I'm so curious well I don't know if this
is related Carl but I know you had a a
recent nature paper I believe that was
about rat cortical neurons where you
know there was there was some
quantitative analysis by which you
determined that it was performing you
know basy and um or AC of inference I
don't know if it's it's related and you
Quantified that but that could be a an
Avenue that's very smart of you because
I was actually just thinking about
should I introduce that as an example of
how you practically do this you
basically reverse engineer the
generative model that could account for
this these bits and the anatomy upon
which these bits play that's a very
difficult game though unless you got
very very basically what you're saying
so essentially what you're saying there
is there is an underlying thing that the
llm or whatever does and you know all
its bits yeah now you try and yourself
construct another model like you might
use another llm to try to construct a
model for the first llm that is
explainable question it has to be
explainable that that's the the other
other
explainable yeah right I mean the the
the problem is I I understand that
science tends to be about making an
explainable narrative for how things
work in the world the problem is I think
that that's at odds with some the things
that you will need to have something
where you can genuinely say that has a
model of itself because I think that to
have in a in a sense the itself is doing
things which are not explainable at that
level if everything that we did was
fully explainable I don't think we would
ever consider ourselves to for example
have choice or free will I other words
if we could always exp I don't think it
has to be fully explainable though
because there is there is the
uncertainty baked into at least the free
energy principle so if I have a
generative model of my own actions in
the world there's quite a bit of
uncertainty and so I'm computationally
bounded maybe I carve off 20% of my
computational resources to that to that
activity but it's not going to be a it
won't have perfect
Fidelity okay okay so so then the
question then that I would ask is okay
you're saying that even though it's not
going to get it right all the time
you're saying that that even getting it
right some of the time is and having
kind of a a self model that is an
approximation see because cuz you know a
very simple approximation is just to say
it's going to generate another token
that's a very coarse approximation
you're saying you want a finer
approximation but not so fine an
approximation that you really actually
capture all of the Dynamics it's some
intermediate level of sort of Co grained
approximation that is sort of uh you
know good enough but not too good I I
mean I I do think these distinctions are
uh I mean I think some of these
distinctions are sort of core to the
notion of what observers like us can be
like and I think it's interesting to try
to home in on you know just what is the
right level here because I I my own
guess is that some of what we perceive
about the universe so let me give an
extreme example it'll be interesting to
figure out whether the fact that we
believe perceive space to be roughly
three-dimensional is a consequence of
some aspect of us as observers it's not
obvious to me I think it's possible that
that's the case and in other words that
that we could perfectly well describe
the universe as being
one-dimensional where you know we have
to chase along all these worms that sort
of you know navigate through space so to
speak the sort of space filling curves
arranged through space but that would be
a very weird and inefficient way for us
for observers like us to describe the
universe and so my my you know this is
why I'm curious about kind of what is
the nature of observers because I think
that the nature of observers once we
understand it better we're going to say
why do we see the universe the way we
see it and the answer is going to be
because we happen to be observers like
we are just as we can say why do we see
the night sky that we see well it's
because we happen to be at this
particular place in this particular
Galaxy and so on so well this and this
you know this maybe in the spirit of
asking a bit about the ruad uh isad and
I think this links back because you
asked a couple times you know can you
imagine a universe in which it's just
not possible for there to be persistent
observers like us that are able to
survive because there's not enough you
know predictability and I kept thinking
you might be in a very good position to
answer that question because one
takeaway I took from a lot of your work
on computation and the Caton really a
new kind of science is that look of all
the possible calculations out there most
of them are pretty boring they're either
very random or just some boring you know
line that goes on forever there's this
tiny tiny sliver of computations that
have this this chaos this this Advanced
nonlinear kind of complexity you know so
I'm curious when you're when you're
building the bruad and you start off
with some type of substrate some type of
hypergraph and there's a set of rules
from which you know the laws of physics
emerge you know how much fine-tuning has
to go in there like of all the possible
rules um which what percentage is it a
small sliver that produce interesting
behavior and what's your intuition tell
you about of that sliver that produces
interesting Behavior what fraction of
that would allow for observers like us
right well so everything happens in the
ruad so it's not we don't get to choose
or fine-tune anything about the ran
itself what we do get to choose and F
tune is what part of it we are sampling
now when I say choose it's like there is
an entity that is sampling every
possible part of it but an entity like
us is the the there are aspects of
what's going on that we sample now when
you say things that are interesting
that's a deeply sort of human Centric
thing to say because what's interesting
to us is a certain set of things that
well what's interesting to us is what's
interesting to us I don't think there's
a try as we might with I don't know you
know any kind of you know information
theoretic you know algorithmic
information theoretic you know all of
these things in the end I think devolve
into well it depends on how you do the
course graining it depends on what you
think the underlying generative model is
etc etc etc and all that reflects right
back on us in other words I don't think
there's an absolute notion of what's you
know what's interesting and what's not
you know when you talk about compression
for example this question of compression
uh at least is is always it's like it's
a question of well what's the machine
that is doing the decompression if you
say you know you can have if if you're
doing something like you know
traditional you know Shannon style
information Theory you're you're usually
using things like block coding and so on
where it's a very definite simple model
of what the compression and
decompression process can be it's um so
I think you know I think this question
of what's interesting it turns right
back on us I don't think there's an
absolute answer to that and you know
when you ask well what about all the all
the alien intelligences that aren't like
us well most of those alien
intelligences will be so different from
us that we won't recognize them we won't
you know our
AIS are perhaps our first really good
example of an alien intelligence that by
Design we arrange to be quite aligned
with us I mean we don't even get that
for your average whale or something we
don't know how you know we can't really
understand its intelligence because it
wasn't built to be aligned with us so to
speak our AIS are built to be aligned
with us so we get to have a much more
sort of I think you know it's much more
plausible to have sort of a a
communication with that sort of human
aligned intelligence or human aligned
kind of uh uh set set of things that are
going on that there's there's a lot of
interesting stuff to discuss but
unfortunately I I am quite running out
of time here so so even though I it
seems very unfair because i' I've been
been um uh would you like to come back
for around 2.0 or were we uh commit we
commit to explor more about the
yeah right well I I'd be um but but
maybe I mean if if we have just a a
moment more I mean car if if you um it
sounded like you had sort of a pent up
uh set of questions here and I I'd be um
uh um maybe at least a preview of the of
the pent up questions or something would
be would be
interesting okay very briefly because um
I appreciate you've got the rest of your
day to to to to live out in California
which is where I presume you are
oh I'm I'm I'm in I'm in the east coast
actually so I'm three hours okay but but
I'm but I'm a late schedule guy
so so I I was just really interested in
um you're listening to to to you um talk
about the ruad and thinking about us as
observers as part or a slice or a
Slither of of this um whether there
would be any mileage in using the notion
um of bounded computation read as a a
markof boundary or a markof blanket
based upon the implicit what I imagine
is some kind of um adjacency Matrix that
inherits from the sort of hyper
graphical construction of the ruad so I
I was just wondering if there's any way
of of sort of um thinking about
identifying certain patterns that do the
sort of diverging and merging again and
then
give the impression at a certain degree
of cor scening or persistence in the in
the sense of there being a you know like
a pullback attractor an attracting set
of arrangements and that that could be
operationally defined with a Markoff
blanket which is Trivial to do once you
got the adjacency Matrix you can easily
identify the Markoff blanket of Any
Given set of states and then you could
call those an observer so I just wanted
to know whether that real simp really
simply
simpleminded view of the ruling ad as
basically being whose Anatomy was
described by some neighborhood
relationships at a very very small scale
um
was was an apt a starting point for
understanding the nature of the ruad
right right right so I mean essentially
what you're saying is can you separate
off things objects that have sort of
sparse connection to other parts of the
system yes it's unfortunately more
complicated than that okay so an example
of something where you can separate off
aspects of it are black holes where
because what makes even the structure of
space is there isn't any notion of space
until you have activity in space so
you're building up this causal graph of
all the different events that are
happening and in order to even have a
notion of space you need a kind of kind
of whole ocean of those events that
that's that's what makes space so in a
sense there is necessarily connection of
some kind between everything in Space by
virtue of those many events having
happened the only place where you can
sort of separate that off is when you
have an event horizon and where you can
sort of say no there's really no
dependence from this to that or at least
no dependence um when you when you're
not dealing with multi-way systems and
quantum mechanics and so on um so I I I
don't think it's quite as simple as that
I mean is there a way to kind of
understand the statistics of the ruad
and ask not whether there is any
correlation there certainly is a
correlation because otherwise space
wouldn't hang together but whether there
is a significant correlation a
correlation at some Co grained level I
think that's what you have to go for and
that's again just technically vastly
more complicated because you have to
Define what's a useful course graining
procedure the very definition of what a
useful cor scening procedure is is going
to lead you into questions of observers
and so I I don't think it's a it's it's
a vastly more complicated at a technical
level it's a vastly more complicated
kind of question but it's I think that's
a very reasonable thing to to be going
for it just isn't easy to achieve except
in these rather straightforward very
space-time oriented cases like event
Horizons but I think that that's uh you
know I I would love to have a a good
characterization of you know I've got a
piece of ruad and I can view this piece
as being an observer like piece as
opposed to another piece that would be a
lovely thing to be able to do um I don't
know how to do that and in a sense in a
sense that was what I was pushing you on
but the difference between a you know a
rock and a brain um is uh uh is asking
for that same kind of thing um I think
it is yet more difficult in the case of
ruad just because it builds up
everything and so you you you kind of
you don't get so so so one of the things
to understand and this relates to
thingness and markof blankets and so on
perhaps is this notion that is very
critical to science as we have as we've
pursued science so far that you can have
isolated things in the world that you
can have an experiment you do where you
say this is an experiment it's on this
thing and nothing else in the world
affects the thing I'm looking at that's
a you know that notion of of
factorizability about the world is
something that I think I I think that's
what you're going for with this kind of
malov blanket idea if I'm understanding
correctly and that notion of
factorizability I think in some
fundamental sense what the ruad tells us
is there isn't ultimate factorizability
there never will be the only question is
for the things that we choose to look at
is there some effective theory that we
can think of as factorizable it's at
least enough that we can have sort of
definite thoughts without always being
affected by other things in in that
happen in the world and I you know i'
I've well it's interesting more more to
think about here I I like your um uh I
think this notion of um observers who
kind of actively pick for themselves the
path of predictability I think is
interesting I I I still feel like I need
to untangle that idea a little bit more
I feel like there's a there's a bit more
and you've kind of indicated that you
see there as being some tautological
character to it I I I kind of feel like
it has a a um I I would suspect that
there is something which you
are something interesting which you're
effectively taking as acatic about
observers and and perhaps perhaps some
uh that I mean in a sense one of the
things I'm trying to do right now is to
think about what aspects of observers
are in fact there but we've always
thought they were obvious in other words
the idea that there could be pure
motion you know that's always seemed
completely self-evident and obvious but
yet I think it's something one has to
derive and so I'm sort of curious about
as you peel back you know what things
are there about observers that have
always seemed totally obvious to us but
in fact
it might not be that way and and trying
to understand that um and that's uh
that's kind
of yeah before you can have pure emotion
I guess you even have to have a thing
that that's moving right and it sounds
like in the context of the ruad do we
even have a mechanism of identifying
persistent things or not I mean is there
is yeah it's a bit coarse right now I
mean we can identify things like black
holes because they have a very definite
structure and their causal graphs right
to identify things like electrons is
something we are not yet able to do
although I have this very strong
suspicion that which was even really
highlighted by this video that that we
just made um electrons and black holes
are not that different I think even
though this has been a very popular idea
for a long time right the the black hole
electron there's so many similarities
between between an
electron I think people have told me you
know I'm I'm I'm remembering when I was
like 15 years old or something maybe 14
years old or something I went to some
talk by some well-known physicist uh and
you know I I sort of said but you know
they were talking about black holes and
I was like is there something you know
similar between electrons and black
holes and it was like no no no that's
completely silly idea you know you
should forget that idea um there's so
there's so much that's similar and then
there's just a little bit that's off
right it's like not quite doesn't quite
match well I think the thing that I
really enjoy is the concept of why is
the why are all electrons why do they
all seem the same and a black hole you
know your average black hole all the
different black holes in the universe we
imagine they were made from the crushing
of completely different stars but to the
outside of the black hole they look the
same and so that leads one to the kind
of amusing idea that all those electrons
all those 10 to the8th electrons that
there are in our universe that seem to
all be the same maybe actually each of
those individual electrons
has sort of a crushed civilization
inside it that's different but to the
outside of the electron they look the
same and that's uh and now and now we
have to start talking about those uh to
the you know those observers that live
inside the crushed civilization inside
the electron how do they feel about sort
of uh how do they um uh how do they kind
of uh conduct their lives so to speak
and are they like those uh those
creatures we were talking about earlier
inside the inertially moving spacecraft
who are who are like uh having this
whole you know they're having a whole
giant um uh you know that they're giving
lots of speeches all inside the electron
but nothing outside the electron can
tell that there's that there's anything
going on there um Al so just real real
last quick and Carl I'm sorry for taking
the time here but for the for the the
black holes which you can identify in
the ruad are they able to experience
pure emotion
well H to observers who have certain
characteristics they will appear to have
pure motion but for example the knitting
together uh one of the things that
actually is pretty tricky it was even
tricky in making this video which is
kind of an interesting thing is in order
to make the video we had to have we had
to it took more effort to constrain The
Observer than to work out the underlying
Dynamics in other words to to to render
the video required
aligning sort of different pieces of
space at different moments of time and
keeping those coherent and that took
vastly more computational effort than it
took to do the underlying dynamics of of
what was going on and so that's that's
kind of highlights the fact that you
know we had to make an assumption about
the Observer The Observer thinks they're
standing still The Observer is not
zipping around all over the place The
Observer believes they're stuck they're
persistent in time and they're stuck in
more or less the same place in space if
we didn't have that we wouldn't be able
to make a video that anybody recognizes
even though the underlying Connections
in all these hypergraphs are all
absolutely correct we just wouldn't be
able to see that so it's a um so in that
sense uh you know we can say that to an
observer with those
characteristics yes black holes are
persistent things um and and those
characteristics by the way this is all
reflected in in the in the traditional
treat treatment of general relativity
there are uh it is you know the this
business about aligning things is if you
don't do that even in standard numerical
relativity you end up with all these
weird coordinate singularities that kind
of that kind of shred your space um so
anyway this is uh uh so it's it's kind
of fun that we get to see even in just
we're trying to make a video it kind of
forces us to think about these
scientific questions about what how
observers work and how much effort it is
to be an observer how much effort it is
to kind of successfully knit together
you know these these things that that
sort of are happening underneath in the
universe
um well anyway this has been I I have to
run off here I I don't want to but I I
I'd love to go on and and and chat some
more but I I see I'm actually two
meetings late so I think have to go back
to my day job um Keith maybe just before
we wrap up could you recapitulate some
of what we were discussing earlier which
is similar to what you just said now and
I I don't want to say that you are an
agency chauvinist but you were just
saying that there might be one
particular way of demonstrating agency
and earlier on you were saying okay well
we should look at the overall system and
there is a distribution of agency it's
it's it has lokai all over the system
and you could draw a big boundary and
say well that thing's
has agency but you could be much more
efficient and you could draw a smaller
boundary and that smaller boundary would
have almost all of the agency of the big
boundary because most of the things in
the big boundary are just mimicking or
stealing agency from things in the small
boundary so Keith you were saying it's
really important for us to incapsulate
the most agency possible which is to say
the most amount of temporal planning in
the smallest
space yeah and so what I had in mind
there Carl was just that imagine imagine
I'm I'm a pilot steering a ship
okay and if somebody looking from the
outside looked at the ship they may
decide that the ship as a whole is an
agent you know it's planning like
obviously it's planning it navigated
through you know the Suz canal and some
locks and whatever else but but there's
a smaller subsystem if we had the
ability to analyze this we could find a
smaller subsystem which is the pilot you
know this human being who's sitting at
the controls who's actually the the
agent right and maybe you could shrink
it down a bit further and say it's
really just all his his brain it's
everything inside of his skull that's
kind of doing the planning but then we
realize that agency actually has the two
sides of the coin like it has the
planning side of the coin which is only
happening up in here but the inaction
side is perhaps different because if
you're looking at the all the Machinery
necessary to enact the plan it's the
Pilot's brain and the Pilot's body and
the ship itself and all its components
so I think you you know you can come up
with a different boundary if you look at
the an active piece of agency versus the
planning piece of agency but I think you
do need to on the planning side you need
to at least shrink it down to that
minimal system that contains the the
actual planning